welcome to episode 7 of the stronger by
science podcast in today's Q&A episode
we answer a variety of questions about
things like CBD supplements the concept
of junk volume several questions related
to muscle growth and hypertrophy and
finally Greg answers the question about
how he managed to build a following in
the fitness industry if you want some of
your questions answered on a future
episode check out the links in the
description and send your questions our
way thanks for listening and enjoy the
show
welcome to the stronger by science
podcast this is your host Eric Trexler
I'm here with temporary co-host Greg
knuckles and you know we expected not to
not to feed a fed horse Greg have you
heard that expression it took a second
to sink in but yeah that's uh that's
what I'm familiar with yeah so that
that's the new way to say beat a dead
horse now you don't want to be that grim
so you say to feed a fed horse it sure
would have been nice if you if you gave
us a trigger warning before using the
original yeah before unleashing that
verbal assault
well we'll edit that out but you know I
don't want to feed a fed horse here but
we knew that even though the fitness
podcast format is intellectual property
of the stronger by science publishing
Empire kind of fits under the corporate
umbrella we've established we knew that
people were gonna try to steal that I
mean that was expected I thought it
would take at least 10 episodes before
we started really influencing federal
policy in the US government but much to
my surprise it you know the loyal
listeners will know maybe a week or so
ago as of the recording date here we
released an episode with Rick Collins we
talked a little bit about how it sure
would be great if the government
clarified some positions on CBD oil as a
supplement and wouldn't you know it like
three days after we said that the FDA
comes crawling and saying oh look we're
gonna go ahead and clarify now I mean
they know that we as American taxpayers
pay their salary
when we demanded answers they gave
answers that's that's how a response
this responsive government and illiberal
democracy works you're right I mean this
is an example of the government getting
it right they listen to the podcast and
they said yeah we ought to clarify they
had a meeting and then the press release
comes out but the reason I bring it up
so we're gonna keep doing Q&A episodes
every other week but every fourth week I
think we're gonna start doing federal
policy episodes if there are any federal
policies or laws that you'd like some
clarification on or you'd like updated
or revised go ahead and send us which
federal policies you'd like us to get
working on because the CPD one that was
quick three or four days and we've
really made some change yeah and I mean
if if we're being honest and forthright
here we probably don't yet have quite
enough poll to say you know do a
constitutional amendment maybe more than
once per year so if there's anything
like inherent to the basic structure of
governance in the country make sure that
make sure that that's something that
you're really serious about before
sending that in but like basic federal
policy that's that's no big deal yeah we
got you there so again that'll be every
fourth week from now on but the normal
question and answers we're gonna keep
doing those as well now this week we did
get a question that actually was about
CBD username e 10 e 10 e 10 e 10 said
seriously CBD has to be bogus what is
your opinion on the topic and a CBD
stuff so if you listen to the the
episode with Rick Collins or if you read
the stronger by science article one of
the cool things about CBD supplements is
that the CBD is not supposed to be a
supplement so that's like a not relevant
to its uses but it is a fun fact that
like that's going to be a very active
thing to keep an eye on is how the
government's going to deal with making
those products available and overseeing
quality now CBD has actually obtained
FDA approval as a drug but only for
seizure conditions so there are a couple
forms of epilepsy for which CBD has been
approved
as a pharmaceutical drug now there are a
lot of anecdotes out there about you
know CBD helps with recovery your
anxiety or stress or whatever the case
may be and a lot of those anecdotes are
just that they're anecdotes there's
there's not a tremendous amount of
evidence to really go with in terms of
clinical research another thing to keep
in mind about CBD supplements is quality
control in until a supplement really
gains traction it's hard to know whether
or not you can really trust that you're
getting a pure potent unadulterated
product that that has exactly what's
labeled and doesn't have what's not
labeled now there are according to
examined calm right now there are about
a hundred and ninety trials ongoing with
CBD that's wild
so CBD is an active area of research I
you know just because it's anecdotal I'm
not one to just kind of dismiss it I
mean anecdotal evidence is still
evidence you just have to interpret it
as such you know so what do we know from
the evidence the evidence would suggest
that for some particular seizure
disorders there's some some application
but everything beyond that at this point
it's pretty much anecdotal and the one
thing I would say is I would be very
didn't so at the fitness summit this
year in Mike T Nelson's presentation
didn't he present some like reasonably
strong evidence that it may it may also
be like a decent prophylactic for
concussions he did mention that have you
looked into any of the studies on
concussion no I mean I just generally
trust Mike yeah I didn't really follow
up on it I I when it comes to the on
label approved application of seizures
oh yeah from that is where most of the
rigorous evidence is I would definitely
believe that there is preliminary
evidence available pertaining to brain
injury there are some things looking at
anxiety pain things of that nature
but when it comes to the the more robust
findings that you can can really take at
face value I think right now the the
limited utility that you see CBD being
approved for pretty much solely pertains
to the seizure stuff so I mean you know
there's a hundred and ninety Studies on
going I would imagine at least a few of
them are on other outcomes so there's
certainly preliminary evidence in of
other areas that may or may not pan out
you know there there are some some human
studies that have looked at things like
anxiety and pain but I'm I'm more
hesitant to to make any strong
conclusions especially when it comes to
the fact that the the oversight of
quality control with these supplements I
really don't even know where to begin
and that that's something to keep in
mind is that there are kind of maximum
thresholds for for THC content at which
you would say it is a you know illegal
CBD product how well does certain
manufacturers adhere to that it's hard
to say at what doses can you potentially
fail a drug test I frankly do not know
so I get pretty hesitant to recommend it
but it is an area that I'm I'm
interested in yeah and and one of the
hang-ups as well is like if there's a
supplement with say preliminary evidence
maybe like a fair amount of decent
anecdotes and it seems like it has a
good safety profile and it's cheap then
that's easier to give like a light
recommendation on and say like yeah you
know maybe it's worth a shot but the
thing with CBD is like the the
efficacious dose is reasonably high and
reasonably expensive so it seems like
unless you make really really good money
it seems like a reasonably large gamble
just because if you're gonna take enough
for it to theoretically possibly do
something you know you're probably
spending a couple bucks a day on it
which you know compared to most
supplements you would take if you buy
wholesale you
you may be spending like between five
and twenty five cents a day so you know
it would be a lot easier to recommend to
say like you know we're not really sure
about any of this stuff but if you want
to try it try it if it was cheaper but
you know that's a that's a that's a
non-negligible financial cost for
something that possibly does nothing or
possibly like you said could have some
negative effects if there are issues
with like purity and manufacturing or
just side effects we don't know about
yet yeah and when the FDA sent out their
press release they didn't mention us by
name but it was for us you can read
between the lines but they also mention
that that they were a little bit annoyed
that CBD has become this widespread
supplement that's not actually a
supplement because they're like we
really haven't looked into a lot of
these other you know what are the
potential drug interactions what are the
maximum safe doses things of that nature
they the FDA put out a statement saying
we're really not certain about those
things and until we are we'd prefer that
people not just kind of haphazardly
start manufacturing and distributing
these products onto a slightly more
conventional question that were more
used to dealing with Quadzilla
eighty-three asked the question does
volume or intensity drive strength gains
is it one more than the other or a
combination of the two yes oh that's a
good question and in my opinion it
it depends pretty heavily on what time
scale you're dealing with so in the
reasonably short term it's much more
intensity than volume there it's not
even worth citing specific studies to
back up that point like there's there's
a pretty clear dose response curve in
terms of like higher intensity training
to a point tends to lead to larger
strength gains during the the time
scales that are typically studied and
researched so you know between like
maybe a month and a half and five months
like that
that's about as long as studies tend to
go so in the short term like absolutely
intensity over so over the short term
there is meta-analytic evidence and I'm
blanking on the on the name of the lead
author of the meta-analysis but there
was a meta that came out last year
looking at the effects of volume on
strength gains so looking at like one to
five sets per week versus five to nine
sets per week versus ten plus that's per
week and basically like the higher
volumes did lead to larger strength
gains than the lower volumes but the
effect size was pretty small it was like
a Cohen's D of 0.2 which is like right
at the cutoff between a trivial and
small effect and like the percentage
chain or like the percentage difference
was reasonably small as well so over the
short term there's there's pretty good
evidence that you do make larger
strength gains with more volume but the
effect is a lot smaller than what we see
for intensity and it also kind of seems
like a poor bang for your buck type
investment where you know maybe you're
doing three times as much training for
like ten percent larger strength gains
however I think there's also a pretty
strong theoretical case to be made that
volume is very important for strength
gains in the long term
so again drawback of a lot of research
is is they're looking at the effects of
these variables over a reasonably short
time scale so you know weeks to months
and so you're not really looking at you
know how does this affect me over like a
ten-year training career and one of the
things we do know about volume is that
it's very important for hypertrophy and
during the short term especially unlike
beginner to intermediate lifters most of
the strength gains you get is going to
come from like neural adaptations
improving technique etc hypertrophy does
also contribute to strength gains but
it's rel
of contribution is considerably smaller
than those other factors but over the
long term it should play a progressively
larger role as you kind of tap out some
of those other avenues for strength
gains so there's not you you know there
aren't like 20 year long training
studies out there to really hang your
hat on and say we know for sure that
volume is a major driver of strength
gains in the long term but I feel like
that's a pretty strong theoretical case
that yeah in the short-term intensity is
is the most important training variable
for strength gains but over the longer
term like volume plays a progressively
larger role if you solely do
high-intensity low-volume stuff you'll
make strength gains pretty quickly but
you probably won't develop enough muscle
mass to keep making solid progress over
the span of years and years and years to
keep making progress you probably need
to put more muscle on your frame and
that's going to come more down to volume
so as an extension of that for someone
who competes in powerlifting could you
make the argument then that
theoretically you know that the time
that they're spending away from
competition it might make more sense to
emphasize volume and then really ratchet
up the intensity in the weeks or months
leading into competition oh for sure I
mean so what one of the things you tend
to notice is so like not in all cases at
all times but for the most part the most
successful lifters in each weight class
tend to be among the shortest lifters in
those weight classes they're the people
who have been able to pack more muscle
onto a smaller frame and also like
they're just more jacked than the
average competitor in that weight class
yeah it's like that that kind of cliche
saying right and powerlifting there's
height classes not weight classes yeah
yeah if you're too tall you got to fill
out into a bigger class yeah like
occasionally there will be someone who
comes along like John hack who's like
510 or in metric what would that be like
178 centimeters give or take competing
in the 83 kilo class which like
that's pretty tall for an 83 kilo lifter
but I mean John hack is just a God he's
no lying
yeah so like so like he alright so like
he makes it work but like every other
good like world class lifter in that
weight class is much shorter than like
the typical 83 CAC yeah like there are
certainly exceptions but yeah for the
most part the the common expression
weight classes are high classes in
disguise tends to hold say yeah like I
think that I do think a lot of lifters
stunt their development not necessarily
like in the long term because I think
eventually most people tend to wake up
to this but in the short term like you
know you do a beginner program you make
some gains training is good and then you
you start hitting a wall you start
plateauing and you realize like oh if I
cut volume a little bit and really
ratchet up my intensity now my numbers
start moving again and that feels good
and I think people experience that and
then kind of get married to that style
of training for a little too long and
then you know a few months to maybe a
year later they hit a much much harder
plateau where you know they're kind of
lifting about as much as their current
level of muscularity can support and I
think at that point a lot of people do
wisen up and realize like no I need to
pack more mass on my frame but yes
that's that's something that I would say
most like a beginner to intermediate
level power lifters should be focused on
for at least like the first four or five
six years of your training career once
you're you know once you've like filled
out a class and you're pretty confident
you're not gonna be able to fill out the
next one yeah then maybe you want to
make more of your training more specific
for more of the year but until you get
to that point and you find like that
natural highest weight class for you I
think you should probably be spending a
pretty good portion of your year on just
trying to get jacked
that may make you a little bit less
competitive in the short term but I
think it's gonna pay off for you in the
long run yeah I like the way you phrase
that I'm paraphrasing because my memory
is not great but you mentioned people
get to a point where they're lifting
about as much as their amount of muscle
mass can support and lately there's been
this kind of revived debate of whether
or not
hypertrophy really does make meaningful
contributions to strength and in the
short term you know looking at
laboratory research over 8 12 16 weeks
you can probably find instances where
there was a very muddied correlation
there but to me that's where the it
really jumps out at you is like you
start to see where people it's like well
based you're just not gonna really get
stronger until you put on some muscle
you know what I mean and those are not
the people that we study yeah so a few
times I've asked a very pointed question
to people that I wouldn't necessarily
say make that claim but at least put
forth that argument that you know maybe
building muscle isn't all that important
for gaining strength and I'll say to
them like look the first powerlifting
meet I did I competed at 165 but I
weighed in at 152 you know I was a very
very easy water cut away from being a
148 you know since then I've competed at
220 I've competed at 242 total close to
1,900 my gym total is pretty close to
2,000 like that and that's the number
that I'm like really really trying to
hit one day dog if I could cut back to
148 and total to K or even 1,900 or even
1,800 I would be comfortably the
greatest power lifter the world has ever
seen in terms of you know like wilkes
points IPF score or whatever like that
would be a ridiculously dominant
performance and so I'll say to them like
look if you're really that confident
that hypertrophy is not contributing to
strength gains if I can tell me I'll cut
to 148 and take the world by storm but
like how much do you actually have like
the courage of your convictions here
like
do you really think I'd be able to get
back down to that weight class without
sacrificing any strength and then that's
where the conversation kind of goes dead
so we've got a related question about
volume this one is B to the fifth the
question is do you think that junk
volume is real or is all volume
productive that's a good that's a good
question and I think that there's I
think that there are a couple different
ways to answer this so I think the
practical answer is that junk volume is
real I think a slightly less practical
answer is that all volume is going to do
something the question is more like is
the additive effect of additional volume
going to be noticeable or is it going to
potentially be counterproductive so you
know you impose a stimulus on your body
it's gonna do something you know on like
the microscopic cellular level like at
least something is going to be different
from doing that eighth set instead of
stopping at the seventh it may not be
particularly large or it may be like a
small effect that's negative because
maybe you've like exceeded now your
ability to recover from that session or
recover as adequately but I think the
term junk volume at least to me sounds
like it has the implication of like this
extra volume isn't doing anything and I
think on just a pure physiological level
it's doing something it's just a
question of whether it's enough to
really notice or whether it would be
beneficial or potentially detrimental
and so I think on a practical level like
yeah like junk volumes a thing if you're
doing you know if you're doing like 30
13 sets in a workout instead of 12 like
did that 13th set for a given muscle
group do enough to really make much of a
difference probably not
or like let's say fear
you do like four or five really hard
sets for an exercise and then you you
know cut the cut the load by 50% and
then do a triple to end with technically
that's more volume but like the last
sets gonna be so [ __ ] easy it's not
gonna do anything noticeable see I like
I think practically junk volume is a
thing but I think that you should you
should recognize everything is doing
something that's just more of a question
of whether the effects are going to be
noticeable or not
what's that you who mentioned the
concept of like hard sets as a means of
quantifying volume or my getting mixed
up so I got the idea from Nathan Jones
he wrote an article for four at the time
string theory back in like 2014 I think
a long time ago and yeah so he he is who
I got that idea from and then I think
I'm probably the person who's
popularized at the most but credit where
it's due
that was that was his concept that I
ripped from him shout out to Nathan
shout out to Nathan so yeah I think
that's kind of a that conceptually
drives really well with your explanation
there of like it's not that the other
volume doesn't count but like if you're
really cutting to the chase and talking
about like with what volume is making
really substantial meaningful
contributions like that's a nice way to
operationalize it I think okay next
question we have from Jessie if we say
that metabolite accumulation may play a
causative role in hypertrophy shouldn't
that mean that supplements designed to
enhance the pump actually increase
hypertrophy so this is a good question
and I might be so just to start with
what would you analogically compare the
feeling of the pump to
I would just leave that to Arnold
Schwarzenegger you know he he I feel
like he did such a great job with that
there's no need to replicate her I just
wanted a sound clip that I could use
against you at some point yeah I'm not
taking that bait everyone listening to
this clearly knows what we're talking
about if you don't it it's out there so
I always view this question through the
lens of nitric oxide boosters because
that's what I've done a lot of research
on myself you know that there is the
thought process that metabolites
accumulation and cellular swelling both
do contribute as mechanisms that are
conducive to muscle hypertrophy so the
idea would be well if we are essentially
engorging the muscle with additional
blood by increasing the hyperemic or
blood flow response to exercise
theoretically shouldn't that help in
terms of promoting hypertrophy and what
I would say looking at the nitric oxide
literature is it's certainly possible
there are rodent studies in which
they've looked at it kind of both
directions they've used very potent
methods to completely blunt endogenous
nitric oxide production and in those
studies it's essentially blunted
hypertrophy in the muscular add update
adaptations to to overload on the flip
side they've given really potent nitric
oxide donors more potent than you would
get in like a over-the-counter
supplement and in those studies they've
actually seen the hypertrophic response
to training increased and don't they
also use models of like venous ablation
where they just completely obstruct
blood flow out of a muscle so that you
get like crazy metabolite accumulation
24/7 to see pretty crazy growth from
that as well I haven't looked at that
literature the scope of what I was
looking at was purely NO donor
donors eggnogs walk aid I was asking a
question but yes that yeah that research
is out there okay
pretty frequently outcome across studies
or I'm like God these poor these poor
mices some of the research methods are
just just gnarly and when I come across
something like that that one is a very
interesting experimental model and two
is just like very cruel it sticks in my
head for both of those reasons yeah the
I mean like there's like the stress test
where they basically almost drown mice
you know or rats and just say well I'm
sure they're stressed out because
they're essentially drowning and they
they measure their responses to that to
that stimulus my example of that is
there's a lot of a lot of the early
research on leptin and leptin receptors
what they would do is it's kind of like
a horror movie but they would fuse to
rodents together so that they shared
blood streams mm-hmm and so that they
would have linked circulatory systems so
these these poor little guys would would
live connected to each other sharing
circulation and depending on what they
would do with you know different
ablations of certain parts of the
hypothalamus it'd be like one side of
the the mouse pair would become obese
and the other would starve to death due
to the satiety signals oh sure like it
would stop eating Ochs like it was you
would see some really wild stuff or or
in some cases like you would see rodents
that became so their appetite was
increased so much they would actually
cause accidental death from eating so
much that they choked like ravenous
feedings Jesus so there's some yeah
there was a lot of weird stuff that
happened to a lot of mice over the last
couple hundred years every now and then
you run into it in the literature and
you're like god that's that's rough yeah
the the people who who are reincarnated
as as lab rodents clearly had karma
working against them like they they did
some bad stuff yeah if you're gonna be a
rodent like I'd much rather get scooped
up by an owl yeah that's gonna be a lot
a lot easier anyway I think we're
talking about nitric oxide remember
so now the question is theoretically
that could be the case I mean it could
be that some of these supplements that
enhance the pump which is essentially
nitric oxide supplements in most cases
it's possible that they could be
promoting hypertrophy I'm only aware of
one maybe two studies that actually
looked at long-term strength and
hypertrophy adaptations over time that
the one that comes to mind is by
Willoughby's group where they use the
the citrulline combined with glutathione
but it was a very low citrulline dose
and what you saw was that none of the
groups really had meaningful muscle
growth if I recall that study right
but yeah the general takeaway from that
study was it wasn't a lot of muscle
growth going on in general in response
to the program now there there are some
theoretical ways that nitric oxide could
contribute to hypertrophy so it has been
shown to have some role in Satellite
cell proliferation it could be you know
it in the short-term these supplements
do seem to enhance resistance training
performance to some degree for a big
huge ride up on all that evidence we've
got an article on the site stronger by
science calm slash nitric oxide one of
the things you made me aware of about
nitric oxide which I had absolutely no
idea about because I was thinking of it
primarily as as the vasodilator is that
it can also cause changes in gene
expression via like nitrous elating DNA
which is like a epigenetic modification
which like for something as simple as a
night nitric oxide I had no idea could
do that yeah so like there could be
effects that we just don't know about
yet oh yeah I believe man this is me
digging deep from like late night
reading
I believe it's estimated that there are
over 3,000 potential protein targets for
nitrous elation and similar covalent
modifications from nitric oxide and
nitric oxide related metabolites so yeah
there's probably at least a couple or a
few thousand proteins that nitric oxide
can covalently mess with and cause god
knows what effects I mean if it were
really pronounced we'd probably know
yeah yeah it was like a huge effect but
but yes I don't mean to be like you know
what's lurking in your nitric oxide you
know like yeah it's fine but but yeah
nitrous elation is it turns out like the
mutant x-gene is just like people who
hyper express nitric oxide synthase
exactly that [ __ ] up all of their DNA
and now they can shoot fire out of their
fingertips or something exactly now I am
glad you brought up nitrous elation
though because the more that I look at
nitric oxide supplements and their
effects when it pertains to strength
performance I am increasingly convinced
that blood flow actually has not much to
do with it if anything at all I think
when you look more closely at what
nitric oxide seems to be doing within
the muscle it can Knight Rasul 8 the
ryanodine receptor and so that's really
big when it comes to calcium release
from the sarcoplasmic reticulum so it's
possible that nitric oxide via nitrous
elation might be enhancing calcium
release particularly in fatiguing
situations and it also seems that nitric
oxide enhances the sensitivity of
myofibrils to the release of calcium so
when it comes to nitric oxide and you
say what what what does it really do for
the lifter I think you could make the
argument that via increased blood flow
and metabolite accumulation maybe it
enhances hypertrophy I think you could
make arguably a stronger case that due
to acute performance enhancement maybe
that helps you achieve the higher
training quality over time and
that could also be a contributing factor
now the big caveat is we don't have
long-term research really seeing that
pan out so for now it is you know highly
theoretical in nature I think there
could be some enhancement of hypertrophy
from these supplements that that enhance
nitric oxide but I I'm not sure really
how much of that would have to do with
the metabolite accumulation or cell
swelling yeah so - two other things I
would add on that is one the the
question like the actual text of the
question asks if we say that metabolite
accumulation may play a causative role
in hypertrophy then blah blah blah so I
think one of the the things we need to
clarify as well is the Assumption here
is that metabolite accumulation plays a
causative role in hypertrophy right
which also we don't know that to be true
and there's some evidence suggesting
that it is in fact not true so the
reason that that became like an idea
that that folks latched on to is in some
experimental models what you see is the
groups that experience the most or the
largest metabolite accumulation also
experience the most hypertrophy but we
don't know that the metabolite
accumulation is actually a causative
factor so another thing that metabolite
accumulation does is it can lower
recruitment thresholds and actually
increase motor unit recruitment and so
if we assume that mechanical tension or
like recruiting and adequately fatiguing
like the the pool of muscle fibers if we
assume that that is the primary driver
of hypertrophy then metabolite
accumulation isn't necessarily playing a
causative role it's playing a secondary
role in that it helps with motor unit
recruitment so that that could be more
of its play and so what we know about
motor unit recruitment is that if you
take a set to failure or probably pretty
close to failure
you're going to be accomplishing
essentially full of recruitment another
thing that we know is that like there's
quite a bit of research now looking at
like heavier training versus like
considerably lighter training and the
longitudinal effects on hypertrophy the
Assumption here being the lighter
training would cause more metabolites
accumulation so talking about you know
doing sets of 30 40 reps at 30 percent
of your max versus doing you know sets
of 8 to 10 a lot of research now looking
at with that and finding pretty similar
hypertrophy between those those
different loading ranges which calls
into into question like the independent
causative role of metabolite
accumulation in hypertrophy but one one
other thing I would throw out there for
vasodilators so what Rex was talking
about was would be mostly things like
nitrate supplementation or like
citrulline supplementation and this may
have been one of the things you had in
mind with rodent research but something
that is also a pretty potent vasodilator
that humans like can't actually get
their hands on and maybe independently
hypertrophic in normal doses is
sildenafil or in other words viagra
there's been at least one study and I
think there may have been two studies
looking at viagra supplementation in
mice using like a human equivalent dose
that would be similar to a dose of
Viagra that a person would actually take
finding that that it actually increased
hypertrophy pretty substantially so I
think man I think that would be a super
interesting human study because I mean
viagra has a has a solid safety profile
other than the fact that it's prescribed
as a drug I can't see why people would
be like super leery about studying that
as as a dietary supplement you know yeah
I know like whenever you submit
manuscripts or submit IRB
a lot of times they ask if you're doing
any off-label use of drugs so I'm
assuming that's what that refers to and
I'm assuming that opens a whole can of
worms
well yeah but I mean it's it's something
that has been on the market for a long
time and has a very solid safety profile
I mean they're there to go for it like
cocaine for example does have
therapeutic uses like it's it's
sometimes used as a like analgesic for
nasal surgery for example but like you
might have a hard time getting an
off-label use of cocaine by an IRB but
something like viagra I I could
definitely see some I could see a fair
amount of schools having like a big
problem with you studying that but I'm
sure that they're understanding IR B's
out there that would sign off on it yeah
I could see that especially if you're
housed in a not exercise science program
to be honest like if you're operating
out of a more medically oriented program
I would imagine you have a much higher
probability of getting approved for that
you know you get some M D's on board and
do everything on the up-and-up
I just I just think that would be cool
I'm with you all right yeah there were
there were a couple jokes I was
considering making but I don't I don't
think we've quite earned that as a
podcast yet just let him go yeah okay so
moving on to the next question by Alex
and grinnin I've read that having a
lower body fat percentage is more
conducive to building muscle / strength
is there truth to this or is the change
in body function / hormones negligible
between high body fat and low body fat
percentage so basically if you're trying
to get jacked and strong should you cut
first is that going to kind of set the
stage for more muscle growth larger
strength gains well let's start out with
kind of the hormone changes we see with
different body fat level
it would be true to suggest that once
you you know individuals with obesity
tend to have lower testosterone and
higher estrogen levels compared to a
normal weight control group so you could
make the theoretical it would be true to
suggest that if a obese person with a
great deal of excess body fat lost some
body fat and obtained a leaner body
composition it that hormone profile
might look better
the estrogen might become reduced and
the testosterone might bump up back into
a higher kind of resting level now the
caveat is once you get too lean then
you're kind of screwed you know it
talked to any natural bodybuilder when
they're when they're really lean ready
for a competition like the the
testosterone levels that you see in
natural bodybuilders are honestly
comical like the reference range I
forget the the units but it's like three
hundred to a thousand or three hundred
to eleven hundred for for most young men
you'll see values like a hundred one
hundred and fifty like I've been under a
hundred and fifty before when I still
had a lot of weight to lose for a
competition and so is that the the prime
spot to be in for muscle growth
absolutely not
now I also wouldn't speculate though
that I would definitely say when you're
in that position SuperDuper lean yeah
you're not really in an ideal hormonal
spot for muscle gain and we don't see
people recount rebound from that with a
lot of muscle get gain right out of the
gate I've done a couple studies on
really lean bodybuilders and looking at
their body composition changes in the
first like four eight twelve weeks you
almost always gain a huge proportion of
fat in the initial weight regain period
now on the other end of the coin I do
find it hard to believe that if you were
obese that you would struggle to put on
lean mass due to the the magnitude of
hormone variation we see up there I mean
have you ever seen any research on that
yeah so two things I'll add so first off
the I think the the line of research
[Music]
influencing this question in the first
place or really like the study that most
people cite is the study by Forbes back
in the day where I can't remember if it
was like an over feeding study or if he
was like compiling results of like
various overfeeding studies but the the
net effect was that when you overfeed
lean people something like two thirds of
the weight gained is lean mass and only
about a third is fat mass and when you
overfeed overweight and obese people
about two thirds of the weight gained as
fat mass but only about a third as lean
mass so I think that's where the
Assumption underlying this question
comes from like when you overfeed lean
versus obese people what ratio of lean
to fat mass do you do see and one thing
to note there and and you are getting at
this with your answer is there's there's
a path dependency such that people who
are lean and have always been lean are
probably physiologically different and
metabolically different than people who
have previously been considerably
overweight and are now lean so you can't
necessarily assume that the same
principles will apply because if someone
is lean and has always been lean they're
probably not getting those reductions in
androgens reductions in leptin and there
may be thyroid hormones and various
other things that come with getting lean
whereas the person who used to be
considerably overweight and has now lost
a bunch of weight may have some of those
issues going on in terms of in terms of
like obese people or people with a lot
of body fat having issues putting on
muscle a fair amount of that is is based
on
there have been I think like two or
three acute muscle protein synthesis
studies looking at lean versus obese
people in response to protein feeding or
resistance training finding that the
post prandial or the post-workout
elevations in muscle protein synthesis
smaller and obese people than than
leaner people but there's a difference
there between like people who have a
fair amount of body fat but are also
like a very active and doing a lot of
resistance training versus people who
are obese because like they just don't
exercise at all and are very sedentary
so I believe one of the things that that
you studied while you're at UNC was
looking at muscle quality in lean versus
obese people both in like general
population and also football players
finding that muscle quality is assessed
via like ultrasound echo intensity if
memory serves was very very different
between lean and obese general
population folks but like muscle quality
looked pretty good in pretty obese
football players so so that leads me to
believe that there's definitely some
confounders here where it's it's
difficult to extrapolate from people
who've always been lean versus people
who've always been overweight to folks
who have been overweight and are now
lean and there's also issues
extrapolating from overfeeding studies
in the general population versus like an
athletic population of you know maybe
powerlifters are strong men who are you
know very active and are probably
metabolically healthier than their body
fat levels would suggest taken in
isolation and honestly dog like I think
just the existence of super heavy
weights falsifies the assumption that if
your body fat gets too high you're gonna
have a hard time putting putting on
muscle and gaining strength cuz right
yeah you know like the supers are
stronger than the like
one hundred twenty-five hundred twenty
kilo lifters like they just are their
body composition siddur ibly stronger so
one would assume that they have
continued to be able to put on more
muscle than they would have been if if
they were leaner probably yeah that's
kind of what I was getting at is that
there are cross-sectional studies
showing like yeah obese versus lean
controls the obese males have higher
estrogen lower testosterone but I just
can't basically I mean what you're
saying like if you want to find somebody
with a lot of lean mass find somebody
who's like semi athletic and 340 pounds
like that's where you're gonna find the
lean mass yeah so I struggle to believe
that it actually prevents you from being
able to put on lean mass well I mean
like I have no idea what Ray Williams
hormonal profile looks like yeah but
like I can tell you dude doesn't have
great body comp but he obviously has a
shitload of muscle yeah yeah definitely
like I think I think that's pretty clear
yeah so I if your only goal in a vacuum
was muscle gain I don't see a scenario
where you would have where you would
benefit from losing fat to achieve that
goal however the reason I brought up the
physique athlete stuff and the
bodybuilding stuff is if you were to
take that very literally and get super
lean thinking you're setting yourself up
for hypertrophy you're probably gonna if
you get lean enough you'll you'll be
shooting yourself in the foot there so
you know you need to be a high enough
body fat to actually produce androgens
at a meaningful level yeah yeah okay we
got a question here from how do you how
do you think you pronounce that name
poly Cronus pineapple Asst poly Cronus
I've never heard that name before
I think he's Greek very cool I like it
okay how possible is it that eccentric
overload causes preferential hypertrophy
of Titan meaning that people who only
perform conventional training are only
getting a percentage of the available
gains sub-question what kinds of
would you use to test this and you know
what kind of difference do you think it
would really amount to practically
speaking ok so there's there's several
questions here one how possible is it
that eccentric overload training causes
preferential hypertrophy of Titan I
don't know I honestly have no idea I've
never seen that directly studied so I'll
say sure it's possible why not I think
the the practical question here though
is the second question assuming that
eccentric overload training causes
preferential hyper tree if Titan would
that mean that people who only perform
consent or conventional training only
get a percentage of available gains and
there I think that I don't think you're
missing out on much if anything by not
doing ISA eccentric overload training so
one of the things we do know or at least
very very strongly suspect is that
eccentric training causes more
hypertrophy than concentric training so
if you only do eccentric s-- you'll
probably grow more than if you only did
concentric s-- there was there was a
meta-analysis looking at that it was
published maybe like 18 months two years
ago it didn't quite find a significant
difference but I think it was like a
p-value of like 0.06 or something so
pretty close to significant most of the
non significant differences leaned in
favor of a more hypertrophy with
eccentric only than concentric only
training so yeah like you you very
certainly do need to be doing or you
quite certainly do need to be doing some
sort of eccentric training to maximize
hypertrophy the question then is do you
need to do eccentric overload training
or is just the e Centrex you get from
doing you know normal conventional
training sufficient and there haven't
been a ton of studies looking at that
but everything out there that's been
published so far
tends to indicate that there's no
additional benefit from doing eccentric
overload training so the most common
setup you would use for that is what's
called accentuated eccentric so
sometimes studies will just use weight
releasers so just for the first rep you
go down with a heavier load when the
weight releasers hit the ground they
come off the bar you stand up with a
lighter load and then you do the rest of
the set with just that lighter load
there have also been I believe one or
two studies using dynamometer z' with
like different resistances set for the
eccentric versus the concentric part of
the lift and I think there's been
actually I'm pretty sure there's been at
least one study out of Norway or Sweden
one of those one of those Scandinavian
countries where they had a hydraulic
setup such that for the eccentric like
the like hydraulics were pressing down
on the bar harder and then once people
hit full depth like I'm pretty sure they
were doing the squat once they hit full
depth like the hydraulics relaxed and
let people stand up or it could have
been the other way around where that
like the hydraulics weren't pushing up
on the bar for the e centric but then
they kicked in and helped on the con
centric but like really cool hydraulic
setup so I just want to interject that
whole region of the world they do it
right man I was at the University of
you've asked Allah and they took Eric
Helms and I on a little tour mm-hmm most
of their strength equipment including
their dynamometer z' didn't have brand
names they were completely custom
fabrications by engineers that came in
so cool if they wanted to rig anything
in the world to manipulate how they
apply to force they just did it it was
wild man yeah so accentuated e Centrex
have been studied using several
different methods and up to this point
you don't see additional hypertrophy
from it so if if eccentric overload is
causing pref
intial hypertrophy of Titan in terms of
how that's actually affecting you know
muscle cross sectional area muscle
thickness things we can actually measure
it doesn't seem like the effect is large
enough to be measurable enough to matter
so then the next part of the question
what study designs or tools would you
use to test that I assume it would be
you know you could take biopsies and
look at like RNA expression for like the
genes that would code for the Titan
proteins or if there's like some some
particular like region of the Titan
protein that would show up really well
and like a muscle homogenate you could
take biopsies homogenate it and look at
it that way I'm not entirely sure what
the best methods would would be to test
it maybe there's like a staining
technique where you could you know cut
cross-sections stain it look at it under
an electron microscope so I'm not I'm
not entirely sure what the best answer
to that question it would be like what
what the best designer tools would would
be to study that but finally the last
part of the question is if true what
kind of difference do you feel it would
amount to based on the research we have
to this point I don't think it's enough
difference to really worry about yeah if
there's a difference at all like I'm
skeptical that it's causing any
additional hypertrophy whatsoever yeah I
mean Titan is one of those things that
I'm not exactly a dinosaur you know I
got my physiology education between 2009
and 2010
and an even at graduate level muscle
physiology the most you hear about Titan
is like fun fact Titan also exists like
like you're not really getting a lot of
education on that because it's very much
the cutting edge of muscle physiology
trying to figure out exactly how it
responds to different types of exercise
how it might contribute to force
production
this is kind of the new-school stuff
that we're still hammering out as we go
so in terms of converting these these
kind of brand-new findings that suggests
that Titan is a lot more important than
we used to think converting those into
applicable practical strategies I think
we're we're a ways off yeah and as far
as Titan goes I think that if you're
interested in Titan based adaptations
and how that would affect something in
regards to lifting I think your better
bet would be to look at performance more
so than hypertrophy so one of the things
a lot of people know about Titan is like
the protein itself is absolutely
enormous I think it may actually be the
single longest protein in the human body
I believe so
so that's really cool but in terms of
the total protein content of a muscle
fiber it's a reasonably small percentage
like the vast majority of protein in the
myofibrils
is just actin and myosin so like even if
you did cause maybe a little additional
Titan accumulation just because it's
such a small percentage of the total
protein content of muscle fibers I don't
think it would show up as measurable
hypertrophy since it does affect like
sarcomere structure and function to some
degree though like I said I could I
could potentially see an argument for
Titan based adaptations to affect some
aspects of performance so like that may
be a potential thing to look at in the
future but but I don't think that I
don't think it's going to be a major
player in hypertrophy okay next question
we have from Jason Barnes he's asking
about refeeds so the the crux of this
question is you need at least two
consecutive days of refeeding to have an
impact on your metabolism and hormone
levels
so basically our refeeds or diet breaks
beneficial in the long term
you know now you're you're either out of
the deficit at maintenance or maybe in a
surplus for a few days and it seems like
the metabolic effects you get on the
back end
in terms of maybe increased metabolism
are relatively small so you know should
you have refeeds and diet breaks are
they beneficial do or is it more like
two steps back for one step forward just
in general how would you approach
refeeds and diet breaks yeah so when it
comes to refeeds and diet breaks one of
the big questions is how much do you
need to overfeed and for how long that
that's really everybody's question about
refeeds and diet breaks now a single day
of overfeeding if you just go from a
deficit to maintenance for a day it's
probably you're probably not going to
elevate leptin for long enough to
accomplish much of anything that's
really the name of the game if we're
trying to do anything physiological with
a refeed you know because you have to
not only it doesn't just only take time
to get leptin up but you want to keep it
elevated long enough to have all of its
numerous downstream effects and all of
those biochemical transactions to use a
metaphor they all take time so you need
to have leptin elevated for some minimal
amount of time to actually make a
meaningful effect on some of the things
we're hoping to influence so things like
sex hormones thyroid hormone
non-exercise activity even resting
metabolic rate maybe to a small degree
one day is probably not going to do it
my friend Bill Campbell down at USF
really good guy does a lot of really
cool studies out of USF they did a study
that they published as an abstract a
couple years ago where they did a
two-day refeed and the two-day refeed
was again just kind of I think they're
right about at maintenance for a couple
days
and essentially what they found was two
days appears to be the minimum where you
can start to see some measurable benefit
it wasn't huge it's it to kind of get to
the to the root of this question so the
the two day refeed yeah it'll accomplish
some of those other things like glycogen
replenishment in the short term a little
psychological break but it's still a
fairly minimal effect that when you're
very very late in a contest prep might
be small but meaningful for the average
weight loss client or somebody who's
just trying to kind of slim down the
effect would be so small as to be pretty
pretty negligible I would say
comparatively speaking not not that the
effect itself is going to be
substantially different necessarily but
just that it's such a such a small
effect in general you probably don't
have to dig that deep into the toolbox
for general weight-loss now the one
thing I would caution against with with
refeeds is some people take the approach
that you'll see in some research papers
where they they actually aggressively
overfeed for a few days and they
actually do get a pretty measurable
increase in energy expenditure and a
pretty measurable increase in leptin but
the problem is that is very much an
instance of taking you know the two
steps forward and like three steps back
because what's happening is you're like
oh cool I've increased my metabolic rate
by X but you know you've increased
caloric intake by such a dramatically
higher magnitude that it's still a net
negative effect you've still taken in
far more it's a net negative effect for
fat loss and a net positive act for ya
energy status exactly yeah a net
positive in terms of energy balance
which in terms of achieving your goal
yeah is negative but yeah the so so you
you certainly don't want to try to throw
the Hail Mary and say well I'm gonna
overeat by 900 calories over the next
few days and maybe hopefully my
metabolic rate increases by 300
that that's a bad transaction don't make
it so now the question is if if we're
doing these more conservative approaches
that actually do make some sense how
long do you have to do it I'm of the
opinion that two days would essentially
be the bare minimum three would probably
be better when you look at the the most
impressive results in terms of the
biggest magnitude of effect it really
seems to be the diet break studies that
are doing more of like a week or two so
the matador study did the two weeks of
dieting two weeks of maintenance and had
had pretty impressive effects over the
course of that study but the drawback is
pretty obvious like what used to be a 32
week diet is now a 64 week diet you know
when you extrapolate that over a full
weight loss phase it's a very meaningful
increase in the time spent not dieting I
would say the most palatable what's the
word I'm thinking of the most palatable
compromise that I think you could reach
in my opinion for now until we see more
research come out on this I think like a
three week diet with a one week break is
probably a very nice spot to be in where
you know you're still spending the
majority of your time dieting but that
one week at maintenance is probably more
than enough time to do something pretty
meaningful in terms of affecting leptin
and its downstream physiological effects
so if you're trying to do this refeed or
diet break strategy to make a meaningful
effect on some of the leptin based
metabolic adaptations I'd say I'm
thinking three weeks dieting one week at
maintenance is a pretty nice compromise
if you're only going for like glycogen
replenishment or just having a day where
you get to eat a little bit more sure
one day two days will help you do that
what do you think of the setup they used
in [ __ ] what was that lead author's name
the devotee calorie shifting diet study
Oh
so if memory serves what they did in
that study is one group was at like 30
percent deficit per day like every day
and the other group was I believe at a
forty percent deficit for 11 days
straight and then at maintenance for
three days
so basically every two weeks they got
like a 3 day 3 day at maintenance not
not in a surplus if memory serves in
that study they saw similar weight loss
maybe slightly greater body fat loss for
the calorie shifting group and slightly
better maintenance of metabolic rate as
well yeah I know I've seen that one I'm
pretty sure I included that in the
metabolic adaptation article on the site
I do think that the 3 day approach every
other week might even be better than 2
days every week I think there is
something to be said of having a decent
consecutive stretch of time of being at
maintenance and I do think that 3 days
is probably meaningfully better than
than 2 yeah it's it's a bit of a hunch
there's some evidence there but the
problem with comparing like bill study
in that study apples to apples is that
you have to consider all the other
differences in the study protocol which
are quite numerous so I'm leaning toward
if you're looking at shorter diet breaks
that that would still be kind of in
refeed territory you'd want to do at
least two or three days whether that's
weekly or every other week really
depends on how often you can get away
with it but if you're if you have plenty
of time on the front end and you want to
do this thing right and give yourself
plenty of wiggle room then I would lean
more toward the three weeks on one week
in maintenance approach all right final
question final question here we go
Daily Double and Daily Double Ashley
asks this questions for Greg I would
like to hear about your journey
from being the question asker to the
question answerer so not just how your
fitness came along but how you got your
name out and became a person that people
follow in the fitness industry yeah so
this is this is a general story I've
told multiple times before on other
people's podcast so I guess it's uh I
guess it's good to get it out here on
some some media that I own as well so
the the general trajectory I took is I
didn't really know that I wanted to get
into the fitness industry like I went to
college as a history major but I was
super into powerlifting and when I got
to the Senior Seminar class for history
I realized like I don't actually want
any of the jobs that I could get with
this degree uh and so I just switched to
exercise science because I knew that
that's something that I would find
interesting and I didn't know that there
were really things you could do with
Exercise Science other than like I don't
know maybe be an overqualified personal
trainer or like be a strength coach but
you know I liked lifting I'd been like
kind of helping other people with their
training and programming for a while at
that point so I was like yeah [ __ ] it
let's do this thing and then since I was
like so obsessed with powerlifting I
used to like talk my then girlfriends
now wife's ear off about lifting all the
time and so she was like Greg why don't
you start a blog to try to find other
weirdos who are as obsessed with this as
you are you know that was code for
please stop talking to me yeah pretty
much yeah
and so yeah when I was I believe a
sophomore in college that's when I
started Greg knuckles calm which then
became string theory which is now
stronger by science and yeah just
of sharing my training sharing some of
my thoughts about training and that kind
of just organically grew an audience
from there and then after graduation I
had a job lined up at a gym back in
North Carolina and she got an internship
out in California and it was the so her
backgrounds in journalism and it was the
Dow Jones news fund internship which
like if there's any journalism people
listening to this you'll know that it's
like quite a prestigious Journalism
internship so you know that was a big
opportunity we kind of wanted to get out
and see more of the country anyways so
we headed out to California and I was
kind of in a position where she was only
guaranteed ten weeks I believe so I
couldn't really just roll up to a gym
and say like hey you should hire me PS I
may be gone two months from now so I got
a job as the Content Manager for
juggernaut fitness systems or juggernaut
training systems and that was that was
great but also like so Chad absolutely
paid me a fair amount for the work that
I was doing for him and I don't want to
make it sound like he wasn't because it
wasn't a tremendous amount of work but
also California is incredibly expensive
[Laughter]
Lindsay wasn't getting paid like a ton
for her her journalism internship so at
that point I was like well maybe I
should try to monetize the site a little
more just so uh so finances aren't as
tight month-to-month
and and I'd been doing a little online
coaching up to this point but that's
when I linked up with Omar and put out
the art and science of lifting ebooks
and then they did well and that's when I
realized like oh I can actually make a
business out of this and and kind of do
like the online lifting content business
type deal and then I mean really pass
that the rest is history so that's like
the necessary like biographical
information
but in terms of you know how I went from
someone who tried to start a business in
the fitness industry to someone who has
done like pretty well for myself in the
fitness industry I think that I think
that there's basically two subcategories
there so one I've I've worked really
hard for it and I don't want to make it
sound like I haven't but I also got
incredibly lucky along the way and I can
verify by the way as an objective
observer I mean you you work really hard
you sleep is a new thing for you like
for most of the time I've known you you
worked instead of sleeping most nights
which is a very unique thing so it
definitely should not be discounted yeah
but I also think that a lot of people in
a position similar to mine downplay the
the luck that they've had along the way
and just the amount of good fortune
that's come their way because I mean the
thing is there's a ton of very competent
very bright very hard-working people who
don't who don't make it to the place
that I have and so like a few things I
had going for me that absolutely helped
out is one I'm just like naturally
gifted for picking up heavy things I've
absolutely trained hard to get good at
powerlifting but you know I'm
I picked good parents for it like most
people could train just as hard as I
have and not wind up as strong as I did
and I would be lying to myself if I
didn't recognize that that played a
non-negligible role in at least at first
a lot of people taking me more seriously
than they probably would someone else I
know yeah you're not gonna deadlift 700
with absolute trash genetics or even
average genetics right and yeah you do
deadlift 700 and you think you have
trash genetics you're you're wrong
absolutely hitting yourself yeah
completely fooling yourself another
thing I had going for me is I was
fortunate in that I was able to build an
audience before having to make a profit
on it I think that's one of the things
that stymie is a lot of people's
businesses right out of the gate cuz you
know you're an adult you need to keep a
roof over your head you need to keep
food on your table
and you have a reasonably small audience
and to make things work out logistically
a reasonably large percentage of that
audience needs to pay for your coaching
or buy your products so you kind of have
to push things harder and then people
may be a little more distrustful because
they're like wow this person puts out
good information but I really feel like
they're trying to sell to me all the
time
and so I was really lucky in that I went
to college on a full scholarship with a
stipend and so like I didn't need to
worry about money through college and
when I started the blog I had no
intention of it being a business and so
I had like three like three almost four
years of runway where it was just
something I did for fun and I could put
information out there and it just kind
of organically through an audience and I
could build a lot of trust with those
people because I wasn't having to sell
to them all the time cuz like it wasn't
something I planned on becoming the
business and so I I wasn't monetizing it
and so people didn't feel like I was you
know maybe trying to take advantage of
them to reach my hand in their wallet so
that was that was definitely something
lucky I had going for me which I
wouldn't have done had I not annoyed my
wife as much and just for context that
that scholarship with a stipend did I
have anything to do with the you had
like a perfect SAT at like 14 right well
so that was the National Merit
Scholarship which is based on PSAT
scores okay so I did not have a perfect
PSAT oh yeah I had an 800 math and a 780
reading so
let let it wait look for that one what's
the cutoff for illiterate seven seventy
well you you just you just alienated
statistically 97% of our listeners the
yeah so I mean that's a night a day I'm
close to perfect yeah that's another
thing as well like I wasn't Lee I wasn't
the guy that studied for standardized
tests like I didn't earn that either of
like that was also incredibly lucky
another thing I had going for me is that
when I was 14 and was really into
basketball I wanted to be able to dunk
and I could with like one hand but I
have pretty small hands so that was
pretty dicey so I wanted to be able to
get another like four inches on my
vertical so I could like convincingly
throw down with two hands and I was
lucky that the strength coach I hired
happened to be Travis mash who was at
the time one of the best multiply power
lifters in the world and was just
randomly training people at a Little Gym
in Mocksville North Carolina and so then
when I got knocked out of real sports
due to accumulated injuries and
concussion issues you know he was there
to say like hey this seems like it sucks
now but you're actually a lot better at
lifting weights than you were at real
sports so why don't you try powerlifting
so like without that I never would have
found my way into this world in the
first place in all likelihood and then I
could intern at his gym through college
and he was the one who hooked me up with
Chad Wesley Smith to get me that job at
juggernaut which like I don't think I
really earned that job I think Chad just
kind of trusted Travis and Travis said
this kid is smart he can do the work and
Chad was like cool like I'll give him a
shot so that was also something that was
incredibly fortunate getting that job at
juggernaut got like my name in front of
a lot of people because they already had
a big audience so that was also really
really helpful and not some
that I necessarily earned and so like
yeah I've I started with a lot of
advantages that a lot of other people
don't have and I I think that like I
started with I think a lot of people in
my position acknowledge the work that
they did but they don't acknowledge the
advantages they had and not everyone
who's successful did it with a lot of
advantages like I think some people just
I don't know maybe do truly earn it all
themselves but a lot of us don't but
then the other thing is like as Eric
alluded to I am kind of a workaholic
like if if it's a question between like
getting a little more work done or like
sleeping I pretty much always choose
work I just I love it and it's easy for
me because I really love what I do and
so like it's often times what I would
want to spend my time doing so it's not
like it doesn't feel like work it
doesn't feel like a chore but I do end
up putting in really long hours pretty
much every day so like I get more done
than most people do because I work more
hours than most people do and then I
think like I think one of the things
that helped me specifically as well is I
didn't listen to people's advice when I
started treating this like a business so
one of the things that you'll learn when
when you start a content business is
like you know you need to put out
content all the time you need to stay
top of mind like you need to be showing
up in people's timelines all the time
and you know new content on your site
that you can email people about in
multiple times per week and like I just
didn't do that because I like followed a
lot of people in the fitness industry
that took that approach and it just
pissed me off and most of the time when
I would click on something on their site
it would be like well cool like this is
the same regurgitate
[ __ ] that I've heard you personally
say four times already and I've heard
other people in the fitness industry say
a thousand times already
so I think just like like so it's just a
frequent frequent reminder that they
hadn't done anything new lately right
right
and so you know I don't I don't think my
content is like like crazy mind-blowing
[ __ ] but I at least try to make an
effort to put out things that are unique
or original in some way shape or form
either that's addressing a topic that
either people haven't touched on or not
many people have touched on or taking
the topic that people kind of know about
but going way more in depth than anyone
else would have the patience to just
trying to make sure that like everything
I put out like matters and people aren't
going to to walk away from it
thinking like well [ __ ] I just wasted my
time uh-huh and so both the the amount
of work I do and the the focus on making
sure everything is like high-value I
think those were those were two of the
most important things that were under my
control that I did and then another
thing were where I got very lucky is my
wife Lindsey who like I said her
backgrounds in journalism
once journalism didn't really work out
for her like she came on and she's been
managing the design and marketing and
like business side of the business since
2015
I believe early 2015 and it turns out
that she's really good at what she does
and see yeah like that she is the that
the emperor of the knuckles publishing
Empire yes a yeah so I mean like that's
also helped tremendously I think one of
the things a lot of folks don't realize
is you know if you want to go from being
like the question ask her to the
question answerer
when people stumble upon your digital
domain a lot of times they make a snap
judgment whether they mean to or not or
they kind of look around and say like
does this seem like a professional
outfit or not and so you know that
includes like the design of the website
is it clean
did they make decent font choices if
there's graphics or images do they look
clean and professional when I read this
does it you know does it read like
something I may read from a professional
venue or are there typos every four
sentences and her backgrounds and
copy-editing so that helps a lot with
the typos because I make a [ __ ] ton of
typos and so yeah I mean like people
when they land on stronger by science
are more likely to you know within the
first two seconds of evaluating the site
think like oh the people behind this
seem legit and seem like they know what
they're doing versus a lot of other like
small like Fitness content operations
out there so yeah I mean to bring this
full circle mixture of luck and hard
work I don't think I would be I think
just purely based on hard work I could
have you know been able to keep a roof
over my head but I think that getting to
where I am now like absolutely the good
fortune and luck and lucky breaks I got
along the way played a big role in that
and I just want want to make sure that
that's clear and that that I don't
downplay that all right well we're
approaching the 90 minute mark so that's
probably about time to wrap it up for
this episode as always thank you for
listening if you have questions in the
episode description we'll have the links
where you can ask us whatever questions
on your mind and any federal policies
you'd like to see completely overhauled
let us know those as well
we're signing off and we will see you
next week thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits they
sure you check with a doctor or another
health care professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it
visit stronger by science comm to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you